وجب علينا ان ندقنا قوس الخطر يدق الجيش
السوداني ناقوس الخطر فثمت ما يدعو لاتخاذ
خطوات حاسمه
نحو الشمال السودان تتحرك قوات تابعه
للدعم السريع دون تنسيق مع القوات المسلحه
بحسب بيان الجيش تحركات وضعت المشهد
الامنيه امام اختبار ضبط النفس وطرح
التساؤلا حول مغزى تحركات قوات الدعم
السريع في هذا التوقيت بعد فشل المفاوضات
بين الجانبين في مساله الدمج اعتقد انه
دعم السريع حاول انه يتحصل على مواقف قويه
بنشر قوات وافتعال ازمه لاداره الازمه
الاصليه
يتازم الموقف اذا تسارع قوى سياسيه على
راسها حزب الامه القومي لعقد لقاء يضم
كتلا سياسيه لبحث تداعيات الازمه تعلن
القوى السياسيه عن رايها صراحه ازاء ما
يحدث موقفنا بان هذا التحشيد وهذه هذا
التوتر يجب ان يوقف ويجب ان يعالج بصوره
عاجله جدا ويجب ان تجلس قياده الطرفين
للوصول الى تفاهمات حول نقاط المختلف
حولها
على خط الازمه ايضا تدخل الحركات الموقعه
على اتفاق سلام جوبا كما تسعى الرباعيه
الدوليه لنزع فتيل التوتر وافساح المجال
لانجاح الاتفاق الايطالي فالازمه بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع ووضعت العمليه
السياسيه امام خيارات محدده
اما ان تتوقف وتتجمد العمليه السياسيه في
حال تطورت الاحداث الى عنف او ان يتم
تطوير الاتفاق الايطالي ليستوعب اراء وقوه
اخرى خارج الاتفاق الايطالي واعتقد ان
المؤشرات نحو الثاني هي الابرز
الخلافات الراهنه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع اخذت منحا تصاعديا خلال الساعات
الماضيه فتاثيرات الازمه وصلت الى طور
الانتقال من المربع الامني لتنعكس على
عموم المشهد السياسي في البلاد نزار
البداوي العربيه الخرطوم لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات